ما هو أعلى مستوى نمت فيه على
بعد ميل تقريبًا عندما لا يكون لديك خوف
من المرتفعات ، فهذا ليس مخيفًا حقًا ،
إنه يشبه التواجد في منزل
الشجرة الأكثر جنونًا الذي يمكن أن تتخيله
، مارك سينيت ، إنه
متسلق صخور محترف ويتحدث عنه
النوم في خيمة
يُطلق عليها اسم الحواف الكلية التي
تتدلى من جانب الجبل
الذي كان يتسلقه لأكثر من 30 عامًا ،
وجدرانه المفضلة لتسلقها هي
حقًا تسلق جبال الألب الكبيرة
وهو السعي لتسلق أكبر
المنحدرات على
كوكب الأرض  أوه وهنا يستغرق الأمر بضعة
أيام للوصول إلى القمة ،
لذا عليه أن يخيم على طول الطريق ، لذلك
أريد أن أعرف
ما هو شعورك بالنوم في
بوابة
معلقة على جانب جبل
، الشيء الوحيد الموجود أكثر أو أقل من أي وقت
مضى  الرياح في الجبال
يمكن أن تكون عنيفة جدًا ،
يمكنك تجربة رياح قوة الإعصار
[موسيقى]
هناك أيضًا هذا الشيء الذي نطلق عليه اسم
رحلة برونكو ،
تأتي الرياح في جرف ولا
يوجد مكان تذهب إليه حقًا  pt للأعلى في
النهاية يضربك ويضرب الحافة الخاصة بك
ويمكنه رفع كل شيء
حتى يمكن تعليقك ثم
بالطبع الحافة مثل الارتطام بالجدار
الذي تفكر فيه فقط في البقاء على قيد الحياة
ولم يكن هذا أسوأ ما في الأمر
الرائحة الموجودة على الحافة ليست
لطيفة ،
فأنت لا تغير ملابسك ، فأنت لا
تستحم ،
إنها قذرة شريرة
[موسيقى]
ولكن الناس يحبونها ، فهم يواصلون
التسلق والاستكشاف من
خلال كل هذه العقوبة لأنه
لا يزال هناك سؤال واحد متبقي
كيف تشعر بالطريقة التي تجعلك
تشعر
بها مثل بقعة صغيرة من الغبار ،
إنها تقويها للغاية حقًا
مثل نوع من أكثر الأماكن إثارة
التي يمكن أن تكون على كوكب الأرض